- Ey! What's up, man?
My name is Vandaveon Huggins.
This is my boy,
Mike, right here.
- What's up?
- And we at the Bonnaroo
Festival, we in Tennessee.
You know, we going make a
li'l video and everything
for about the festival.
And we want tell
everybody, like,
we enjoyin' ourselves
and what not.
- Be a little bit
better though, man.
- Like, we havin' a good time
and everything.
- Shit could be a little bit
better though, dog.
- What say,
Go ahead, say it, tell 'em.
- That's it, man.
- He just sayin'
it could be better,
like, we both think the
festival could be better.
So, we wanted to give
like a whole bunch
of suggestions to
everybody, like,
how it could be better, okay.
Like, in the Ferris wheel, like,
we were just talkin' about, man.
Why don't y'all take the
Ferris wheel off the hinge
and just let that
mu' fucker just roll?
And then that's like, what?
- Everything, yo
dick need need to be
this tall to ride this mo'fu'.
(laughs)
Hey, yo dick need to
be, come on, nigga.
Say it, nigga, say it.
- Go ahead, tell 'em.
You don't wanna tell 'em?
- Nah, man.
- It's a good idea.
- It's stupid.
- He's saying,
and then when you
walk up to the ride,
you should be like, yo
dick need to be this tall.
(laughs)
- You bein' stupid right
now, you bein' stupid.
Don't laugh at that.
- What you mean I bein' stupid?
That's your idea, dog.
- I said, I said way more funny
things than that, man.
- He said, "Oh my god,
"I'm sorry, my dick
is only this tall,
"I cannot ride this ride."
(laughs)
'Cause shit need to be funny
at the festival, though.
Shit should b funny
at the festival.
- You gotta take the
comedy up a notch.
- If you take the com, what?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, man, like
the water slide, dog.
- Tsk, shh, you stupid.
- You know, like,
things that you can
do, like, it's good.
- Stupid.
- But things you could
do to make it better,
like instead of
water, y'all should
put champagne in there.
- Yeah.
- So, a motherfucker
just get drunk,
as he goin' down, like I be
goin' on the slide like this.
Ah, and just get it
in my mouth, right?
- You put some, you put
some, uh, titties at the end.
- And then, yeah, like,
have one little slide,
and just have titties
at the bottom.
So, just the dudes
go down that one,
and they go right
into the titties,
and then the other side,
like, you have a dick,
and when the women come
down, they go blip,
right into the dick.
And they can go either way.
They come down like this,
(laughs)
or they can come down like this.
See, put comedy into it.
- You bein' stupid right now.
- These are just the good ideas
that we be thinkin' about.
What?
- They need to, uh, get so you
get different bands,
same stage, same time.
- Yeah, man, there's
one problem, man.
Like, they'll be like
six or seven bands
at the same time I
wanna be seein', right,
but they be at different stages.
What y'all should do, though,
what y'all should do though,
- For real.
- Is have like six bands on the
same stage at the same time.
That's what you
should do, right?
And then I wouldn't
miss no shows,
and like have, who
were you sayin',
like Ludacris should
be playin' all of, um,
Radiohead's songs.
- Yeah.
- And then, and
then, vice versa.
Or-or-or verse vica,
however you say that word.
You know what I mean?
- Basically.
- That to me would
be a good idea.
Then you wouldn't
be missin' no bands.
- Yo.
- It's like, it's like at a
seven and a half right now.
I had to get loud so
you all would know
I'm tryin' to emphasize it.
- It's deep.
- But you wanna take that
shit up to a 10 and a half.
- Gotta be specific.
- Psh, put more dicks in it.
It's like two plus
two equal five.
You know what I mean?
What, Mike?
You say somethin'?
- Two plus two equal dick.
- I'm just sayin',
though, I'm just sayin'.
- See, already, you
can't even help it, man.
It can't make it's self up.
You smell that?
(sniffing)
Oh, we better get
some weed, right now.
- It's all right,
it's all right.
- All right.
So you know, you know
what I'm talkin' 'bout.
- Yo, bring that back.
- Nah, it's this way.
It's, (sniffing) it's this way.
- Bring that back.